welcome back to cbs this morning only on
cbs this morning facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg
is announcing new measures that the
social media company is taking
before the november election now in this
plan that's rolling out today
facebook promises to flag or in some
cases remove misinformation
about voting related to the coronavirus
it will also limit political ads in the
week before the election
in our exclusive interview zuckerberg
says that he wants users to have
accurate information
on the safety and security of mail-in
voting
are you worried about people co-opting
your platform to put information out
that mail-in
voting isn't so safe so one of the
things that we're going to be
doing is at the top of facebook and
instagram
um we're going to be putting accurate
information about how to vote by mail
and how to do it accurately
but we're also going to be acting on
on content that people try to put out
there that that says that it is
fraudulent
if people post content that broadly is
trying to delegitimize the outcome of
the election
um either by saying things like like
voting by mail will
will definitely lead to fraud um or
you know other things that basically
undermine these democratic principles of
methods of voting that we know are safe
then we're just going to add some
context to those posts
well one of the chief critics as you
know of malin voting is that president
of the united states on your own
platform in may he says
there is no weight zero in caps that
mail-in ballots will be anything less
than substantially fraudulent in june
rigged 2020 election millions of mail-in
ballots will be printed by foreign
countries and others be the scandal of
our times july
the 2020 election will be rigged if mail
and voting allowed to take place
we could go on and on so how are you
handling the president of the united
states to let
let him know and let people who are
using your platform that
this is misinformation is it not i
certainly think
that anyone who's saying that the
election is going to be fraudulent
um i know that's problematic and i think
additional context needs to be added to
that this is not just
anyone it's not just a regular joe it's
a president of the united states yes
this will definitely apply to the
president once this
policy goes into place and it will apply
to everyone equally have you personally
engaged with the president mark about
his post
on this particular topic i i don't think
recently um i i have had certain
discussions with him
in in the past and where i've where i've
told him that i thought some of the
the rhetoric um was was problematic
if i did talk to him um you know be
clear about
how uh just
the importance of making sure that
people have confidence in the election
well maybe they'll jump on the phone
later today
some of them could certainly have a lot
to discuss but facebook is taking this
very seriously i was very impressed with
the efforts that they're doing there
they've set up sites on
instagram and facebook to register four
million people to vote before the
election and already
mark was telling me that 24 million have
clicked on yeah to check it out
uh the thinking is some of those 24
million will will sign up so
yeah you know they're going to great
extremes to make sure that
you can vote an interesting choice of
words when he when
he calls it problematic what the
president is doing it certainly is so
we'll see what this context entails very
interested well he knows how to be
diplomatic
we have more of our exclusive interview
with mark zuckerberg in our next hour he
will reveal some of the other major
facebook initiatives
the tech giant is rolling out later
today in an effort to limit
election misinformation